[Music]
every New Year's Day we can count on a
full lineup of football on TV but also
tonight bachelor Ari is going to meet
the full lineup of women vying for his
affection and you know that the first
episode is going to be crazy because the
girls are always trying to make an
amazing first impression so here is a
sneak preview I was so nervous because I
had been on TV for so long so I was
probably as nervous as they were it has
been five years since we saw the racecar
driver as Emily Maynard - runner up on
season eight of The Bachelorette back
then he was dubbed the kissing bandit so
expect lots of steamy lip locks this
season how do you kiss a woman properly
always have good breath timing kiss is
all about timing and you have to know
that the other person wants to be kissed
we also know there will be tears but not
from The Bachelor I'm not a big crime as
Ferraris 29 ladies I just I love strong
independent women they need to be ready
ready for marriage
the women range in age from 22 to 33 he
is 36 and not afraid to break the rules
there are some things that I had to sort
of I had to bend the rules a little bit
to be able to get that clarity this
season there's also a surprise visitor
and no it is not former bachelorette
Emily Maynard I didn't see it coming
obviously because it was so unexpected I
want my girl I'm here to tell her that I
want to marry her
while Arie was just joking when he
pretended to pop the question on
tonight's premiere does he actually
proposed for the finale I think that
things really played out wonderfully
hurt wonderfully sounds like you're
engaged
maybe I'm definitely happy but his
happiness didn't come without drama Arie
admits he said I love you to two women I
really had strong feelings for more than
one person and it was pretty difficult
at the end so it was definitely romantic
both will soon be getting a double dose
of The Bachelor because the Bachelor
Winter Games will air in February to
coincide with the Olympics arch-rivals
villains and memorable alumni of the
show are gonna compete and athletic
challenges how great is that gonna be
including quote the toughest sport of
all love
[Music]
you